the first season of Netflix's
long-awaited adaptation of The Witcher
books remains remarkably faithful to the
spirit of the novels in fact it's packed
with small details that only those
well-versed in the ways of the continent
will notice The Witcher isn't the first
live adaptation of the beloved novels in
2002 actor Mikkel zabrowski played
Geralt in the Polish TV series the hexer
which was also edited into a critically
panned feature film like Netflix as The
Witcher the heck's are adapted stories
from the first two Witcher books the
last wish and sword of Destiny while
mixing in some original elements
zabrowski doesn't cameo in The Witcher
but that hasn't stopped him from playing
Geralt again sorta while it's still
henry cavill 'he's handsome mug that
they'll see on screen polish fans should
find gerelds boys very familiar
Zebrowski is providing gerelds dialogue
in the witcher's Polish language don't
reap rising the role he played almost
twenty years ago though
it's not a detail that most
english-speaking viewers will notice but
it's a nice treat for the polish fans in
the audience who Witcher isn't the only
Geralt adjacent projects a broski has in
the pipeline either the actor will also
dubbed Keanu Reeves his character in the
upcoming video game cyberpunk 2077 which
is made by CD Projekt RED the company
behind the Witcher video games the
symbols that appear at the beginning of
every episode of The Witcher are full of
spoilers but you're only going to notice
if you really know your stuff the title
of each episode is always the same but
the logo behind it changes offering
hints as to what's about to unfold for
example the first episode the ents
beginning features the image of a solar
eclipse if you've read the short story
lesser evil you know that the princess
Ren free was born under a so called
Black Sun leading a wizard to assume
that she was cursed
sure enough the ends beginning tells Ren
free story all the way to its brutal
bloody ending
betrayer moon comes with a picture of
claws and a Tamarian lily hinting at the
curse Striga
the logo for a banquets bastards and
burials is a sword surrounded by a tree
which is appropriate for an episode
detailing the violent history of series
family tree and her time in the forest
in The Witcher characters don't just
speak English magically inclines
characters also use elf ashore the elder
speech to cast spells live curses and
caused mayhem and mischief if you listen
carefully however you might recognize
some parts of the elder speech
vocabulary author Andrzej Sapkowski
based the elder speech on a mishmash of
different languages including Irish
Welsh English German and Latin soon it
became a impediment and broke alone it
became it making but with so many
different sources how does the witcher's
take on elder speech sounds so good
easy the language was designed by a pro
chef Kowski didn't actually create a
fully realized language so netflix had
to bring in David J Peterson to fill in
the blanks does that name sound familiar
it should Peterson is the same guy HBO
hired to create Dothraki and valerian
for Game of Thrones Netflix has made it
clear that the Witcher is based on the
books not the video games but the show
does have one major gaming connection
you just have to watch the end credits
to find it for most viewers the name
Tomek Baginski and play TV Maj one of
The Witcher
executive producers and the Polish
production company that makes the show
respectively won't mean much those who
really love the games however know that
Baginski an oscar-nominated animator
directed the stunning cinematics have
brought all three of CD Projekt RED x'
witcher titles to life in fact without
platies and Baginski
The Witcher probably wouldn't have made
it to the screen at all Baginski who was
also on plat Eva's supervisory board was
the one who pitched The Witcher to
Netflix originally Baginski wanted to
make a feature film based on two of
Kowski short stories
Netflix helped convince him to make a TV
series instead and brought showrunner
Lauren Schmidt his Rick on board the
rest is history the most famous image of
Geralt of Rivia isn't the monster slayer
on horseback riding into the wilderness
to fight some nasty beast it's not
Geralt locked in a life-or-death battle
with a ferocious creature instead it's
the witcher soaking in a wooden bathtub
legs spread leaving only a little to the
imagination
it's a moment from the opening scene of
CD Projekt Reds critically acclaimed
video game The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt
although by now it's become much bigger
cosplayers started recreating the iconic
moment in photographs
CD Projekt RED and Dark Horse created a
statuette commemorating the scene while
Netflix's Show is based on the books not
the games it pays tribute to the scene
in episode 5 bottled appetites shortly
after he meets yennefer the sorceress
lures Geralt into the bath then you can
guess what happens next The Witcher
sword fights are so impressive that it'd
be easy to assume that talented stunt
doubles handled all of the heavy lifting
not true who Witcher showrunner Lauren
Schmidt history told us in an interview
that star Henry Cavill did his own
stunts on the show every single one of
them according to history there is never
a point where you see someone on screen
as Geralt that's not him it's always
Henry in fact that proclamation extends
beyond the fight scenes cavil didn't use
stand-ins even when most of his face and
body is concealed if you see Geralt and
his boot or his elbow
it's cavil on screen cavil was so
dedicated to the role that he wore his
costume including his complete set of
armor while making breakfast or taking a
nap
most extras carried fake swords but
cavils wasn't just real he helped design
the weapon customizing it as he saw fit
for all intents and purposes cavil is
Geralt and
performance is all the better for it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]